これで全部かあっぷわー
結構してみるとすごい実感する今から寝ること
砂鉄をやりますか
僕は
今からな
yeah
burger いまーすわー
デッキを除くデッキは除きます授業はダメません
絶対やめません読めないんですけどもさすがにこの量を見てもらうと分かると思うん
ですけど
カードが重すぎるんですよ1時間2時間飲みきれないデフレのカードの病になってて
ハードを見る時にそんな一日とか時間とられるとちょっとさすがにやばいと思いますね
もっと時間を有効に活用するためにも僕が今後
スムーズに遊戯王カードを楽しむためにも1回9カード全部塗ります
でも
うんですねこれで相手を北こっそりね色んなカード未開封で撮ってるんですこういう
ほんとにねーまじで涙が出そうです
あのお金だけで集めてきたわけじゃないんですよ時間もかけていろんなショップに友達
とだと回って
ちょっと本当に良い出来だった
その
年間がずっとでいろんな人たちと
集めてきたカード
なんですいろんなカード口を探し回って集めてきたはずなんですけど
まあ断捨離というか一回全部塗りますで穴開く
第10 no ame
四白みんたんその思いでも進んでいる
いやー心には取っているからいいますん
関わり入ったけど打っていく方法なんですけどもお店にカードリストというものがあり
ますカードがな円で売れるか全部書いてありますそういう感じでね
1枚だだけので団が書いてあるこの表にチェックをつけ中金どうぞ今から詰めてって
やつはレアカード全部打ってないになるかスレに純粋国車
こんなね光ってはないカードが50円で売れますよこの地ででも200円です
翌日とアラブライフルということですか
なるほど分かりました一番住みてるとほんとで時間がないのでカードレッツを持って
いるレアカードたっけー
ピックアップしてあるお店に来いますどこでやそろばんを求めて日てくれるお店がある
のでチェックなしで見てかなー店よく渡してその合算した値段だ
今回売値になります
アルティマやツォルキン1000円です700
細い余裕ジョーカー道
救急数えます
ねえ飯を盛ったよなぁは終わった子だそう
誰かアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアよ
ああああああ
カイザシーズネック800円でございます
me
神2石1200円です
galaxy 愛と妻さあドラゴン1000円です
になるまでのミラー操作
冒頭は10年だっけ
うーんあの街このために来たよえあるバーじゃない
ああやばい俺あー作るか c とかでそう
通院ついた1枚700円5枚あるのでこれで3500円ですよね
苦労
ありのまま
me
レッカーをて文字1800円です
二枚明日のマダコ1,500円
ギャラクシーアイズプライムフォトン1300円です
ギャラクシーアイズタキオンドラゴン正義100円
数ギター版遊戯王カードつあっております
ファントム大豆ブレイクソード1,000円
me
ペアケアの蔵です1,800円2枚あったりこれで3800円です
1万円かける5が一番5000
0ブラックマジシャンが3,000円
たぶんこれが一番高い5枚あるので15,000円
ブルーアイズオルタナティブドラオ g 1200円です
プレシアの国1,200円
ラーの金貨ません100円です
レアカーぞ
終了でございます
わかる部屋タードを見るだけでも11時間かかるから面白いからこれはノーマルカード
何か探さ撮ってみたら1日どころじゃないですよ
ん
ああああああ
これが全部ノーマルカードん
ねこっちゃにレアカードをまとめてでこれはさっき見てたカードのチェックリストです
ねそこに書いてあった本当に高いカードです本当にもう僕にはあとたから止めるべき
時間がとっています
さっそく行っていきましょう私でないになるのでしょうか
どんくらいだと思う
ん
100ん
はいというわけで1軒目のソップにつきましたこちらでは立つのレイアウトづらい品の
カードた日を打っていきます
あとどれが高いかというとちょっとメモしておきました
買取なんとか私っことができたんですけどもうちょっと時間がかかるみたいで今お昼な
んですけど
夜の10時ぐらいまでかかりそうということなのでもう行ってっぽい子
こちらではさっきもチェックリストに入れた高いカードのみのチェックリストに入れた
高級カードだけを振りにいけますではいってきます
8話によると30分から1時間くらいな例カードでぽちっクリスだったから早いんで
いう
飯候補
入っています
いっ
健全まだかかりそうですね開館したんかなこれは
電話くれるって言ってくれたから夜中にも一角くればいい
相次ぎてサティーがまだまだ部時間がかか輸送だったので多分
終わるのは夜中になりそうですなぜ夜中まで
注定
def
うんん
t you do